Recognizing cabin fever is the best way to deal with it.
The symptoms are well-known: boredom, edginess, irritability, restlessness,...
...and dissatisfaction with being at home or stuck in an office.
Maybe you're even claustrophobic or immobilized by a pervasive feeling of inertia.
Besides the four walls you have to continually stare at during the winter months,...
...the weather equally plays a big role in helping people acquire cabin fever.
The lack of sunlight...
...and increase in cloudy days during the cold winter months gives some many months of hostile despair.
It can strike anytime and it's often relationship - based,...
...especially when someone cares for children or the infirm at home.
Having a moody housemate is another way of getting cabin fever.
Not only do you have to deal with it in yourself,...
...but also face it when interacting with others.
Fighting cabin fever is also sometimes an actual source of trouble.
Try to know the sufferer's character.
If possible, give the sufferer a wide berth to ease his or her sense of confinement.
For some, following a routine and keeping busy can give solace.
For others, it may make the sufferer feel worse.
A temporary change of scenery, calling a friend, or...
...taking a break from routine may also help.
Remember the problem may not be yours...
...but by recognizing it in the person in the next cubicle at work...
...or in someone you live with you can adjust for it.